hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the very
helpful things that George Dickey does
in his piece
what is art an institutional analysis is
to distinguish between three different
senses and we might also say three
different concepts and associated
procedures for identifying or
characterizing or defining what a work
of art is and he tells us that there's
at least three distinct senses of work
of art so he's not saying that this
necessarily precludes additional senses
but we do want to recognize that there
are at least three and these are
distinct from each other so that we
don't confuse them making distinctions
is an extremely helpful thing to do
whenever we get into a controversial or
ambiguous topic and what counts as a
work of art definitely fits into that
that classification so what are the
three different senses he summarizes
them as a primary or classifications and
that's mostly what he's focused on in
this essay on clarifying that
and distinguishing the theory by which
he makes sense of this and provides a
working definition how that differs from
earlier attempts to define art in terms
of say the maysa or imitation or
representation on the one hand and
expression of emotion or experience or
whatever else it's going to be on the
other hand he is going to appeal to what
he calls an institutional conception of
art the secondary or derivative sense is
another way of understanding that what
people mean when they talk about
something being a work of art and
there's you might say there's there's a
looser way of calling something art that
would fit into the umbrella of the
secondary or derivative sense and then
finally we have what he calls the
evaluative sense and it this is
something worth dwelling on there's a
lot of times not just in art but in
terms of all sorts of other things I've
seen it recently in terms of talking
about who counts as a philosopher
there's a lot of cases where people mix
up the primary sense of a term with an
evaluative sense of the term so when
they say so-and-so isn't a philosopher
then you say well I don't understand why
you say that I mean they're writing
things that are acknowledged is as
philosophy they're using the language of
philosophers they're carrying out
analysis that looks similar to what
other people call philosophy why are you
saying they're not a philosopher they
say well because they endorse
conclusions I don't like or they begin
from starting points that I don't like
and then you can say you don't mean that
they're not a philosopher you mean
they're not a good philosopher they're
not what you want to call a philosopher
because you're using philosophy in an
evaluative sense rather than
a class of agat aureus cents so this is
very important when we come to works of
art just you know to take an example
that's very closely connected think
about music when somebody says that's
not music what they mean there is not
that somebody isn't actually making
music there they're making something
that the person wants to say doesn't
count as good music right so there's we
can talk about the class wicket or II
sense and then we can talk about the
evaluative sense let's look first at
what he characterizes as the evaluative
sense he doesn't say an awful lot about
it here but it is definitely worth
looking at for just a moment he says
that the evaluative sense is used when
the object it is predicated of is deemed
to be of substantial actual value so
this is when somebody at least is saying
this is good or this is beautiful or
this is we might use an other aesthetic
terms like this is cool or you know the
old-fashioned you know used to be new
fashioned but now old-fashioned use of
bad to mean good right any of these
sorts of things
something is a positive and substantive
value that's the evaluative sense of
calling it a work of art now notice what
he says about that that could be a
natural object we could say that the
Grand Canyon is a work of art depending
on how we we feel about it but what's
needed in order for that to take place
is some sort of reference or a
ratification by what what Dickey is
calling the art world
if the evaluative sense is going to
stick so to speak right anybody can say
something is good in some sense but
whether others accept that that
evaluation that's something different
let's talk now about the derivative
sense he brings this up in terms of what
he calls driftwood cases right where
somebody takes a piece of driftwood and
says oh wow this is really beautiful
this is a work of art and then somebody
else comes along and says no it isn't
you just pulled that out of the ocean
that's just randomly you know ground up
and eroded wood that you happen to like
and they say well I mean it looks like
that thing in the museum over there that
other people are willing to call art so
that is a good example of something that
is secondary or derivative and what
Dickie has to say about that is that in
these sorts of examples he says it seems
natural to say of the piece of driftwood
that it's a work of art why because it
has many properties in common with this
branch oosik piece and then he's taking
this from from another theorist who says
we could reflect on our characterization
of the driftwood and the direction that
has taken why why do we view this as art
so here's what Dickie says we say the
driftwood is art why because of its
resemblance to some paradigm work of art
or because the driftwood shares
properties with several paradigm works
of art the paradigm work or works are of
course always artifacts the direction of
our move is from the paradigmatic that
as artefactual works of art to non
artefactual art so we might say that a
spiderweb is in fact a work of art
because it resembles or has some things
in common with other things that we
identify as human art and we might do
this with you know birdsong and music or
all sorts of other things as well but
this is calling something a work of art
again in a derivative sense it's not
quite the
thing what about the primary or
clasificado
sense so he talks about ways in which
people have tried to make sense of this
in the past by pointing to some
characteristic like involving imitation
or representation or involving
expression of emotion and he says those
were actually mistakes what we want to
do is think instead about the
institutional nature of art and he takes
Dontos conception of art world which
then he provides a great analysis of
here which we don't need to go into
suffice it to say the art world is a set
of people institutions machinery all
sorts of things coming together that
help to perpetuate works of art and to
identify them as such so he says having
described the art world I can provide a
definition of the work of art so this is
a class for a definition what is it he
says a work of art in the class victori
sense is an artifact a set of the
aspects of which has had conferred on it
the status of candidate for appreciation
by some person or a person's acting on
behalf of a certain social institution
the art world so that is a different
sense a primary sense of what would be a
work of art this may not be all that
satisfying to people who want something
that's a bit more readily identifiable
that doesn't require any sort of
reference to you might say a
sociological phenomenon or historical
phenomenon of the art world but this is
what he is preferring to us as the best
definition of art and that is a classic
Atari
sense of work of art a work of art is
something that is identified as a
candidate for appreciation on behalf of
people within a certain social
institution that is the art world and
secondary or derivative senses come from
that primary sense by reference to
certain objects or paradigms and then
the evaluative sense would be saying
well this is good or this is this is bad
but that would be something distinct
from the primary or class victori sense
you